Váu tụi tới nướng chính phủ, phạm tị thân tra đã đồng ý với để sợt của bộ nội vụ,
về phương án nghĩ tét dừng lịch năm 2020, kéo dài bố nè linh tục.
A bụng lội với công trước, vinh trước và quyền phích người lau đồng thực hiện vụ hợp.
Tại văn bản số 1 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 4 2, phó tụ tưởng chính phủ, phạm tị thân tra,
thống nhất phương án nghĩ tét dừng lịch năm 2020, không tra hai sấu, theo để sợt của bộ nội vụ.
Theo đó, công trước, vinh trước, lực nghĩ bố nè linh tục, ử tướng năm 2020,
tháng 10 năm 2020, đến hết chúng nhận này một bọn tháng 10 năm 2020.
D nhưng nghĩ lể được thực hiện thong qua hóan đổi ngày là em việc thứ sấu,
này 1 2 3 40 năm 2019, xáng 14 vạo ngày ngày hàng tần thứ 7,
này 1 1 50 năm 2020, đối với người lau đồng, phó tụ tưởng quín hết người xưa dụng lau đồng.
Háp dùng thời giann nghĩ tét dừng lịch năm 2020, tưởng tưởng như đối với công trước, vinh trước,
lom thời bảo đảm đầy đủ, các chi dầu, quyền lợi theo quy định của pháp b潤,
và các thoát thận có lợi hơn trong người lau đồng.
Phó tuấn yêu cầu vụ trường lợi vụ, thông báo phân án nghĩ lẽ đến các cơ quan hành chính, đơn vị sửi nhập tổ chức chính chỉ sã hội, ráng nghiệp và người lâu rộn.
Các cơ quan, đơn vị, cân bổ chỉ lực lợi ứng trực hợp lý bảo đảm sải quyết công việc liên tổ phụ phụ tốt như cầu của nhân dân.